shall we
waiting on you cold sip of refreshing
water I want to squeeze that in your
face so [ __ ] bad
what's up [ __ ] we're back with
some oh [ __ ] feelings gang
welcome back [ __ ] feelings I'm your
host Kevin James Ryan with me as always
the greatest comedian of all time Toby
McMullen
the king of the one-liners gang welcome
back to hard feelings I'm your host H
Foley this week
got Kevin James Ryan in the building say
hi to the folks out there all right mop
you up I don't like this I don't like
that you're telling me to do stuff
what's up everybody do it anyway yeah oh
I gotta say hi to the [ __ ] homies of
course ten dollar homies the twenty
dollar home he's a 50 homies the
lifeline the bloodline [ __ ] love
these I go to the mattresses for you
both oh yeah you got anybody bothering
to give us a call we're gonna get our
asses kicked I'll get beat up in front
of you yeah and a nice quick shout out
to our producer short and air Toby
McMullen everybody what's up what's up
good man got the new [ __ ] headphones
for us cleaned up the studio real
[ __ ] nice yeah chipped in while we
were gone good man yeah [ __ ]
fantastic time we're here we were not in
L.A I was down the shore we got a lot to
cover this week sure a lot of things
going on probably probably kick it off
of me huh yeah
I'll kick you out of here
anyway so me and the cat got real cuddly
yeah I am playing fortnite no pizza's on
its way no it shows up there's no wings
I was like listen no it was Taco Bell
and Call of Duty [ __ ] I'd say you
did it all weekend hey I took that
twitch I got that thing home I'm [ __ ]
all those switch whatever it's called
playing that Mario Kart check in will
you having a good time I'm sure that
gets her all wet Mario part with an old
man Mario Kart
I play Luigi just Luigi
you got something to kick things off you
got any beef I played Wiffle ball uh
somebody get him out of here
uh by yourself no I have to watch this
pop-up you run out and grab I got
something uh you were all pissy with me
the one night and I like because I was
sleepy time
yeah I mean he's not good with the he
likes things on his terms no that's not
the term we agree to terms and then you
just throw those I got tired okay I
wanted to let him stay and hang out with
his friends over there at the Kennedy
store but my phone was dying do you see
how he said you're mad let me tell you
let me control this narrative as to why
you were mad
what am I an idiot I'm not controlling
and narrative
it's the first thing you do after you
take out Communications and cut down the
[ __ ] cut down the energy Supply
you can't float a bridge will you take
out the fuel dumps and start controlling
air sure from your perspective you are
like I want to go home and I was like
just wait a half hour or something is
what I said when you're tie Thai a half
hour okay but let's let's beep beep beep
let's back this up I don't know about
[ __ ] five hours it's like four
o'clock we're like what do you want to
do we did something during the day we
had a pot or something we did something
during the day in L.A we both go back to
our respective quarters
um it's like at the Tommy Hotel it's
like you guys wished on a monkey paw and
they're like we'll give you success but
you have to hang out all the time I know
it's not great uh no I love it uh but
you know this is just a very
fully thing so it's like four right and
we go like maybe I think it was even
like two it was like early in the
afternoon we're like let's go [ __ ]
shut it down for a couple hours we did
this a couple of times in Los Angeles
and it was all yeah we're like we'll go
shut it down for a couple hours uh you
know whatever whatever so like two turns
to four for the record hang on
a hotel room about 32 degrees Yeah it
was chilly Willies Penguins where'd you
guys say the Tommy Hotel not the
Thompson that's how things kicked off
all right I did drop the ball I'll give
you that drop the ball in the hotel but
the waiters we'll just give the the full
run down we could talk hold on let me
just get this story out before I [ __ ]
bamboo you I see what you're trying to
do so two turns to four turns to six
we're supposed to meet pot Josh Potter
former guest good old pal at The Comedy
Store for some beers and some Bernies
ain't he's there's no one better to have
beers and Bernies outside with than Josh
Potter good man it's a good guy so we go
he'd be great in a voxel if you can see
the [ __ ] enemy oh man he'd be
shooting you and stuff his eyesight's a
little tweak that kid
no so
um hanging out with Daredevil
it's feeling your face I love it you put
on weight [ __ ] love you salt to the
Earth yeah he's great so
um
I like seven right so now it's like nine
like we gotta we gotta leave we figure
we're me that we agree that we're
meeting past all right in question was
like the second day in hold on we're
meeting Potter at nine right so like we
part ways to say let's go shut up Seven
rolls around there was never a definite
time I know but seven no nine no we said
we're gonna meet Potter at nine yeah
we're gonna meet Potter at nine there
was no talk at dinner so seven I
understand but you know so seven Rolls I
gotta pick and choose five hours later
yeah so seven rolls around I got nothing
from like hey what up nothing a half
hour goes by I know that he's sleeping 7
30. I'm not like we gotta leave in like
an hour right like it takes 45 or takes
15. we gotta leave at 8 30 to get there
at nine I was in a little place called
night night town so then
eight rolls around and I go hey man I'm
I gotta get out of this [ __ ] hotel
room now like I'm like I'm tired or
we're jet lagged around like I gotta
[ __ ] I'm gonna get moving here so I'm
just crawling the walls the whole trip
he's texting me at five in the morning I
can't sleep what are you doing I never
did that I mean pancakes what do you
think I'm doing it texted you at 5am
yeah you're six hey I'm going for a
while I'll show you the text I said I'm
going to 7-Eleven do you need anything
yeah yeah I'm sorry I can't do my friend
a favor but it was early yeah so yeah
yeah
um you were also up
yeah yeah so what's your point actually
was I mean when I was going back to bed
okay here we go yeah so dude eight
o'clock nothing like radio silent to the
point where it's like 8 45 and he's like
where are you at and I'm like what are
we still meeting at nine you had a real
two a wheel just woke up too he went and
had dinner alone what else am I gonna do
you think traveling salesman you you
threw out an okay in the group text
yesterday by the way that made me want
me
yeah I don't do okays made me want to
throw you off of a bridge okay
yeah what was the okay for you were like
we're like do do you want to record it
too and I was like yeah sounds great and
then you were like okay
yeah okay that sounds good no it wasn't
okay that sounds good
no okays are okay hold on hold on I've
done a lot of yeah geez now now we're
canceling okays okay all right I've done
a lot of uh
research on a lot of thought on his
language that he uses a psychology of a
Madman [ __ ] sucks too and the problem
is sometimes he does just mean okay okay
sounds good right but he also the thing
is he also uses okay as a weapon yes I'm
[ __ ] snubbing you which so when you
do get it you're he's [ __ ]
conditioning you to be like this [ __ ]
[ __ ] sucker is a jerk off because he
does know how to use it ruins my day
yeah he does know how to use it to
really piss you off yes you're also the
only guy I know that like tries to piss
people off like that which is crazy I
thought about that I don't think so okay
we just said we just said you do that
okay
that dude you also sent some dot dot
dots sometimes even over this I sent dot
dot dots once and that was during a war
I know you're the only one you start the
war then we're in a war
and I get yelled at for being for
screaming at you hey you gotta do
something to push the stock market up
you know what I mean
a little rattle and hum got a little
treat learn you how to do [ __ ] Sudoku
puzzles yeah Wag the Dog a little bit uh
so it's 15 minutes till meet up and this
guy's talking about a Lobby call which
obviously would have been at least eight
miles seven something and let's meet up
have a Barney a coffee we want to go get
a bus anything but then he's like are we
still me it's like I'm the bad guy
for the him sleeping till nine like I
was okay with sleep until nine I was
upset that you were by yourself for a
little bit that was because of you you
had to have dinner alone also I went to
the worst [ __ ] dude I've never seen
so much bad service we fit in like
[ __ ] two two screws and a peg or
whatever it is over there what look like
bozos me and him trying to hit the
rooftop bar and [ __ ] the schwanky
place
yikes yeah looking like a couple of caps
I know did I tell you we literally went
over to the corner where nobody it was
like back behind like the service
elevator the only thing we needed was a
picture of a missing girl yeah we would
have been [ __ ] I'm telling you right
it was it was if we were not two cool
guys on a rooftop bar you see this go
around anywhere yeah that how I got
heckled at the rooftop bar I say that we
were in there where I the last time we
were yeah what I was I was walking we
were leaving the pool I had a towel
around my shoulders no shirt and some
guy who worked at the you had to walk
through the restaurant to get to the
elevator to get down to the room oh
that's bad and a guy walks by works in
the restaurant and goes stripes are in
this year doing looking good buddy I was
like God damn
at the rights
um but we did have a good we did have a
good hang all all in all no no even uh
wait so what happened with the A45 no he
finally just shows up and then we go
then we get to The Comedy Store it's
about ten at this point so we've been
there an hour the whole gang's there
Gill is [ __ ] Jeremiah Watkins or opal
John McHugh for everything years John
Nunn Irene Morales [ __ ] gang the
whole [ __ ] gaggles they're all hey
Jeremiah I said Jeremiah yeah he was
also there and you know who's on stage
Jeremiah you know who's on stage
hey the window open I can see the stars
he was dude he was sitting there like he
belonged on a [ __ ] star tour like on
the bus he's gone he's right there I see
him he's right there I'm like [ __ ]
act like you've been here before all
right fit nice sweater fit perfectly
expensive jeans hair was perfect he was
in there killing though
um but sometimes when you over nap the
nap stays with you and you're CP
so I started getting sepia so I said hey
I want to get out of here problem was my
phone was at five percent oh so he's
going I want to get out of here I go get
me an Uber he goes it's all going to the
same card it's not like you're paying
for the Uber it's not that I know but
this is the thing you go we go to a
place together I meet up with you late
yeah you ice me all day on a hang
because you're you're napping which is
fine then we link up it's nine o'clock
we go somewhere for an hour and then
you're like I want to go and I'm like
just [ __ ] hang for like a half hour
like we just got here but what was wrong
with you just taking the car later on
and you doing your thing and me doing my
thing yeah sure which was fine I said
yeah call a car but then he goes He but
this is the answer this is where the
Irish dishes I can't even take a I can't
he can't even get himself he's fighting
like a couple he goes I want to go home
I go then go and he goes can you just
wait for me we'll leave together yeah
just wait there's a half hour half hour
out of the way that turned into 45
minutes oh so sorry
we got back there but well your hour nap
turned into five hours and iced me I was
alone I could have been taken by a pack
of homeless people out there they're all
over the streets man I went to a
7-Eleven at [ __ ] 6 a.m I almost
turned around twice it was a block away
it was that [ __ ] wacko out but when
we got there it was all Glitz and glamor
we get there the flight's coming in late
we go straight to the Beverly Hills
Hotel classy joint to meet Mr Tim Delon
Tim Dylan and Mr Ben was also their
director Ben Ben's a sweet tall drink of
water tight jeans [ __ ] nice Blazer
look like he's running the whole Coast
it's [ __ ] sharp
um
we meet them there they're a couple
minutes late he says go downstairs to
the cafe Cabana next to me also first of
all we have to we're so we're coming
straight from the airport we have our
luggage we have to check our luggage at
the hotel that we're not staying at it's
a different world it's not like just
going to like a nice hotel it's a it's
completely different I've never
I've never experienced anything
everybody was smoking hot every but just
cars pulling up we get [ __ ] hot
brewed we get dropped off
and then we don't even get like he stops
like there was like a little traffic at
the valet so we get out like you know I
don't know five see the whole scene and
so we're like step back like we're like
by the parking lot a little bit just
smoking we got our luggage you know what
I mean it's just like I got my CPAP
machine he's got a CPAP machine in his
hand it's a bad look those people are
just like so what radio station did you
win these tickets from Yes it looked
like yes y'all do laundry looks like we
got in the wrong Uber and we got dropped
off there yeah
well we actually won the showcase
showdown we got a week at the world
famous Beverly Hills Hotel we're off to
Acapulco tomorrow